what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we're gonna watch The Last of Us episode
7 today of course Joe and by my great friend
over here Andrew Gordon Igor 7-Eleven
I thought that coconut water sorry about that
man I just got this from The Tipsy bison had
a bigot sandwich so yeah I'm just chilling
anyway guys make sure to go ahead and leave
a lock and after that subscribe and click
that notification Bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next episode is up here
on this Channel full length Ranch and watch
alongs where you sync up with your own copy
of The Last of Us available for our super
sexy Rejects at our patreon page cover a bunch
of stuff exclusively over there also wanted
to announce the real rejects got themselves
an exclusive Last of Us inspired t-shirt take
a look at that you can get it at shopzeroedition.com
it's inspired by that Sean of the dead end
couldn't have Ellie turn into a clicker because
that just wouldn't make any sense don't worry
this scene is not in the game or the show
it would be stupid if it was but it's an awesome
t-shirt that I'm proud we have here at the
rejection Andrew you ready to presumably see
Riley finally in the show Tommy I am or was
that Nicholas Cage from Ghost Rider I don't
know but yes I am ready to see Riley uh it's
been a major anticipation of mine let's do
it let's do it
oh [__] Dragon yep yep guess we're skipping
over that whole left behind stuff at least
the mall part probably I don't know yes we'll
find we'll find out leave shut up John be
good Joe shut the [__] go she's cool
oh
[Music]
flashback flashback yeah flashbacks we're
doing flashbacks
training fedra training well we've never seen
any of this they did mention the Walkman in
the DLC
wow you don't fight your friend fights she's
not here anymore [Music] must be that Gap
when Riley wasn't around you've never been
when I called well behaved but the last few
weeks
don't look at my family Bethany's in the infirmary
with 15 stitches good okay damn 15 seconds
take [__] orders from your patrol leader
will probably be Bethany there's the other
path follow the rules you become an officer
when you're an officer you get to tell the
bethanies of the world exactly where to shove
it guys a fast talker if we go down the people
in this Zone will starve or murder each other
that much I know
which we've seen in other zones there's a
leader in you and one day it could be your
turn so which way
take his keys keys good let's grab him let's
grab him
ah dinosaurs
no pun intended survive and endure endurance
survive sorry sorry I know I'm so dumb
it's so cool to actually see it opened up
and being red
combat two
damn Riley
hang up on me like that it was a joke hey
I thought it would work better terrible jokes
are you okay I'm fine I just ran away for
a bit that's all if you're going through some
[__] you're supposed to I don't know your
best friend about it wait who gave you the
black eye tell me where you were give me a
name and I'll [__] them up it was Bethany
and I already [__]
I joined the Firefly oh [__] you I will
tell you everything first you have to promise
me something sort of crazy and you're gonna
say no but then you have to say yes very perfect
casting on Riley come with me for a few hours
and have the best night of your life
oh yeah
I mean if you get dressed
I like the revamp on having there be more
of an intense reaction to her join the fireflies
so where are we going secret you trust me
right I don't know should I trust you of course
you should with your life guards no dispatch
or something stupid ready this better be good
I didn't have a black eye right I don't believe
she had a black guy in the game at this part
yeah you put Carol in the infirmary for a
[__] week I'm just saying you can't fight
everything and everyone you can pick and choose
what's important good lesson are they teaching
you this at Firefly University
Carol [__] Carol it really is the best
see oh Firefly lights are better that's why
you gotta join okay I'm sorry
two floors [__] you that cardio and I've
been off
oh [__] right no no this this guy wasn't
here yesterday yikes that's scary
how disgusting
it's the drink this guy must have spent every
card he had to get this no one told one Tom
can mix pills with that [__] uh
scary
if yum give me accept or reject the drink
it's great I should hold it down can I hold
your gun
kind of made me swear not to let other people
handle this I don't want to handle my sidearm
because I'm such a [__] Firefly [Laughter]
okay um one night you were in the hole I got
bored so I snuck out I was on my way back
being stealthy stealth and this chick popped
out of nowhere chick like all right no like
40 or 50. she said she was impressed watching
me sneak around and she asked what I thought
about fedra so I told her the truth their
fascistic bags no word initiations nope I
said yes and now I'm a firefly congratulations
as much as I love arguing with your stubborn
ass we're on a mission here [Music]
fun rooftop Adventure today
waking up everyone there
oh my God Matrix leaps
you know I'll begin the [__] yeah so you
don't bomb stuff anymore now when civilians
are around that began to push [__] it's
okay you don't know
and two right here is it gonna be it it is
there the mall it's full of infected it gets
sealed off then why isn't it sealed off
logical questions [Music]
so much careless noise just slamming around
they've been really loud all episode turns
out when Federer connected that block up to
the grid this place got connected too [Music]
circuit breaker turn right open the door tell
me when
[Music]
I'd be so afraid if I was Ellie right yeah
now what
[Music] fun
wow holy [__]
damn [Music]
wait the lights were fine you saw outside
it's like a big bunker no one can see [__]
but us and you ain't seen nothing yet tonight
I'm gonna show you the four wonders of them
all no way electric stairs escalator escalator
go away experience the joy
this was our reaction the first time we experienced
an escalator
uh yeah sure this is the first Wonder oh [__]
it's cool they're playing this song this song
in the second game yeah
dawn of the Wolf and the outbreak happened
people started looting stuff that's gone is
the stuff that people need it the most wanted
I guess toilet paper [Laughter] I mean I don't
get why people back then wanted all this stuff
do you need me to explain it to you it looks
uncomfortable imagine it is I know firsthand
what nothing I was just trying to imagine
you wearing that shut up foreign
go ahead put it on for Riley
I'm on my way so you guys have made so much
noise it wouldn't have mattered if you broke
the window at this point I think she was just
making sure she looked good for her this is
where HBO got all their sponsorships to fund
this product placement do you trust me with
my life apparently oh well then give me your
hand
come on Walker to an arcade [Music]
oh yes
[__]
hopefully she never saw face off
what no way yeah
[Music]
you're a drunk
I remember them drinking this much
[Music]
oh
[Music] word
[Music] no [Music]
oh
like this tone poem like stepping into a independent
movie
oh a clicker turn it off they know how to
operate merry-go-rounds you know we can make
things better could be running things you
could be running things that earlier scene
does complement this better you know what
Quang gave me
sewage detail standing guard while people
shovel [__] what they think of me what
you know you're the one thing I miss from
that [__] place if that makes a difference
no
we're two wonders down three more to go I
want a magic chorus with like a million lights
I don't know how it's supposed to get better
oh there's ways the photo booth is that a
time machine
foreign [Music] to Facebook like in the game
[Laughter]
idiot I was waiting to do it with you
it's expensive five bucks for pictures
um
okay bunny ears wait back to back yeah uh
just scary this was us at Greg's wedding
[Music]
that one's not bad okay they did get him sweet
and they didn't have to break it listen
yes
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
laughs
Mortal Kombat 2 we want to see it
Daytona
[Music] it's great you can't even play once
[Music] I actually get to play you [__]
yeah same [__] that spent an hour yesterday
breaking this [__] open she thought of
everything [Music] there
it is
[Music] how many times I played that game
on SNES [Music]
is going to be Molina yep remember she called
that earlier in the other episode
[Music] do the fatality
[Music] fatality [Music]
I could never do a fatality for the life of
me been here a few times don't wait to do
everything with me
[Music]
yikes oh no
[Music] wow just from The Sound that's four
down dude
[Music]
oh come on next thing oh she really wanted
to kiss her uh it's getting late I just can't
get in trouble again
about you here tomorrow um I got you a gift
honey I do like gifts is it a spider no is
it in your shirt no is it a water pistol it's
better better is that dinosaur possible oh
did you get that reference yeah oh wait wait
is it tacos I understood that one too oh
so much fun spoilery in there
volume two there it is what did the frustrated
cannibal do laid on me he threw up his hands
what did the triangle say to the circle
so pointless
how does a computer get drunk it takes screenshots
what are screenshots I don't actually know
release the Extended Cut oh here we go what
do you call an alligator in a
so uh five bumps we would never use them on
you or anywhere ever near you I would never
let them do that do you never let them let
them yeah I mean I guess we'll find out Ellie
it's okay I'm going Ellie Ellie
none of this [__] was even about me would
you stop Q Ellie Ellie I'm leaving wow they're
sending me to a post in the Atlantic cutesy
good reaction I asked if you could Charlene
said no no Marlene is the lady that helped
me get it doesn't matter why did you bring
me here because I wanted to see you
[Music] I wanted to say goodbye
listen easy Ellie it actually is you just
did it
I have some bras and underwear on the way
out
it's got way scarier I know
oh are we getting the right way
is it gonna be the store
oh yes Halloween store
right the fifth Wonder
I thought you'd like this from the best and
we saved it for last
I guess I was stupid I don't know what it
was like to have a family I didn't have them
for long but I had them I belonged to them
and I want that again ah maybe the fireflies
aren't what I think they are but they chose
me okay I matter to them you matter to me
first goddamn I wanna punch you so bad
it makes you hate me less you're my best friend
and I'll miss you well mate's not over yet
one last thing
[Music] what am I supposed to do with this
put it on stupid why I plug it in you little
thief I was definitely um probably gonna get
it the exact same masks too I love it yeah
yeah same song
give us a roar Ellie oh come on give us a
real Roar
it's so crazy I feel like I'm watching a Natural
Born Killers
hahaha
wow you can feel all the emotions still yeah
oh
I'm sorry
it's worth so me what do we do now we're gonna
figure it out
get ready to run oh
my God whoa
there she's just knocked out what
get him Ellie
oh it's so creepy [Music] oh [__] yeah
yeah
way to go Ellie teamwork just took one holy
[__] oh
must be your first
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no oh
wow [Music] what
even a cold cut geez
it's
like I am not ending up alone again can't
lose another one [Music] she's searching for
supplies I love it
[Music]
wait I see you without two options you take
the easy way out no I don't like option one
this way for everyone sooner or later right
somewhere but we don't quit we don't give
that up
I don't want to give that up create these
last memories I could just be a poetic and
[__] and lose our minds together what's
option three
sorry I'm sorry
thank you stitches
oh that's like the structure of the parallel
in here [Music] the that's really nasty
ouch
[Music]
that was so painful [Music]
Ellie Rising ooh Daddy what'd you think uh
yeah I really enjoyed it I mean it definitely
was a little bit of a slow burn at the beginning
uh in terms of uh Riley and Ellie when they
were starting off their journey and they were
being Extremely Loud they were supposed to
be extremely silent Island but uh no one's
like jumping rooftops and talking very loudly
um but aside from from that nitpick I had
once it like they got into the mall area like
you know I I like some of the changes that
they made from the game like actually seeing
them get to play the video games and some
of this stuff and then some of the expansions
that they made um you know from the game I
I thought were really well done if you guys
haven't played the game it's the is it DLC
it's the DLC yeah but it's a hundred percent
important for the complete package it's not
just like extra fun adventure for you like
it definitely there's a reason they made sure
to adapt it yeah and also to the location
where Joel is when she's having this flashback
memory like they're in a mullet uh or it's
I I don't know if they're in a mall but they're
right near where the University of Eastern
Colorado they were not in a house when she's
having this flashback so that was a different
that was that was a different yeah it was
a mall too well I mean beyond that it's they
the fun the thing about it though is for most
of the DLC you are doing what they're doing
yeah you're actually like killing infected
or anything you're just doing the actual [__]
here yeah yeah I was just talking about the
location with uh Joel Nelly but I think the
thing I love so much about that DLC in this
is there's dramatic irony you know we is you
know we as we as an audience we we know like
what's gonna happen because it's a flashback
whereas the characters don't but it's still
it's very effective and I think that's where
dramatic irony like is can be very effective
and I just think it was written so well in
the game and it's really done well and executed
here and I thought that actress that the guy
who played Riley I'm sorry that I don't know
her name right now she did a fantastic job
I mean the way like after they they got bitten
and you know the way how she was really emoting
and you could see her crying like I mean I
really felt that so much so it was great I
mean the game she was definitely obviously
she was really sad and emotional too in that
in those moments but I really felt it a lot
too uh here and I I love so many the the Easter
eggs and stuff that obviously when we get
to Paul's video into the theory time in spoiler
talk we'll we'll get into uh a lot of the
stuff that I want to talk about more in depth
that I'm not going to but overall it was a
pretty good episode I wouldn't call it one
of my favorite episodes I would say more in
in the mid-tier OR such but aside from again
some nitpicky stuff I had I enjoyed it I thought
you know the relationship between Ellie and
Riley was pretty well fleshed out again you
can't make it obviously as long as it was
in the DLC but given the time frame that we
did have I thought it was pretty effective
for the most part and you know I thought it
was pretty good what about you yeah I thought
it was pretty good too um I think there's
a lot to that this is funny enough you know
um this is one of the harder ones well most
I can do is just be honest this is one of
the harder ones for me to not compare to the
game only because it's really short in the
game like comparatively speaking it's like
yeah you can like complete it like an hour
and a half it's not that long um specifically
the Riley part the flashback as well because
because in the in the game she's looking for
supplies for Joel and having to deal with
Raiders and hunters and stuff but and some
Infected as well but the stuff that just focuses
solely on Riley like that's that's pretty
short and so this was the one where I did
find myself like really impressed with a lot
of how they brought it to life and so even
when I say compare I don't even mean that
in a negative context it's just there's a
lot where you're like oh wow that that is
what impresses me the most is when they do
dramatic scenes like when they are sitting
down together and they're talking about their
two options and wow this is crazy they are
nailing the emotion the tears everything and
like the game and so you have this thought
process going off where uh well at least for
me when I'm watching it like wow that is so
much like what I played and and saw more amazed
and sometimes I'm not as this can be the I
don't know I'm not the only one I know this
is not I know some people have played the
game and they can easily just get completely
wrapped up in it and still be so emotionally
enthralled uh with just with the emotion of
what the episode's trying to do I can sometimes
be in the other side of the camp of people
who played the game where I am I I have an
awareness going on of do you know what I mean
like you have that awareness of that is like
the game and you're watching and you're watching
it so there's I'm like 70 emotion and 30 I'm
aware of I'm seeing I'm I'm also seeing the
cut scene in the game while I'm watching it
you know and uh as I'd love to be just to
complete opposite camp but you know that's
just a reality of the situation so I thought
they did a an excellent job with adapting
if they got all the The Essentials now what
I thought that they did it was really neat
on a structure level is because yeah they
did they skip past a bunch in the game that's
really that would have been great to bring
your life 100 000 but for the choice to save
uh Joel and like as a seasoned structure I
am get it a really clickered with me by the
very end of it because you see Joel lose a
daughter and in the last episode he was dealing
with the fact that he feel like he would be
essentially a handicap a detriment to Ellie
being able to survive and make the ultimate
journey to become the vaccine right and then
you see them have Henry and Sam and that [__]
goes wrong she even tries to save Sam but
can't so she fails there and then you get
this moment with um Riley this whole flashback
where she you know like they've both lost
they have both lost their loves both of them
and Joel is now going to be saved by his daughter
his new daughter his surrogate daughter and
Ellie is going to save is the next person
that she loves is Joel and I think structurally
because it's essentially what the Left Behind
thing is doing in the DLC but for for a tight
50-minute episode I actually think um structuring
it this way was great because you experience
this loss but there's also this hopeful catharsis
that you get when she does end up saving him
at the end with doing the stitching and then
him making the choice too like yes I will
live on I will carry on I like that Joel made
that choice along with her like let me have
a shot at do it you know what I mean definitely
well I mean obviously too there's a major
change because in the game he's for I mean
he's kind of conscious but he's pretty much
he's basically unconscious for the whole time
so I thought that was an interesting choice
but you know also in the snow and [__]
freezing their asses yeah yeah but I actually
I I didn't mind the change where they had
him basically again just echoing your sentiments
what you just said I I like that because you
know there is that emotional gun punch that
you feel when he does like yes I I wanna I
wanna survive I want to move uh fight on like
because from that moment he had at the beginning
of the episode where he's like like get away
from me I'm I'm I'm a detriment to you like
I I failed you like and then you know that
moment that he has it's kind of like a mini
Arc in the episode for Joel so I found some
reason he's kind of just going around aimlessly
and then he finds a reason to live yeah no
I I just that's why I love the change like
it's it's a good payoff to the change I think
in that moment at the end like when you hear
Greg and I like it's give that awe when they're
holding hands like that's that payoff for
me of why they made that change I'm like okay
that's I'm glad they made that for sure yeah
I love the parallel of you have the whole
handing with Riley what they are saying goodbye
to each other because they both believe they're
gonna die yeah and then you have a different
one where they get to live so and um yeah
I think you know from the gamer perspective
of bringing the mall to life and everything
was awesome and and uh uh the what I want
to know her name I think she's the one who
plays the sister in Zendaya's sister in um
that famous show that I've seen all of euphoria
uh I think I think that's her but I I do want
to know her name because it's bothering me
I feel like I would know it it's not storm
read that's a completely different actress
no I'm thinking of someone else it is Storm
read okay okay you had it who plays oh no
no that other girl plays Storm an X-Men apocalypse
that's right my mind was getting confused
there all right yeah I figured it out also
too I thought they had really good chemistry
her and belly and just so everyone knows does
he keep calling her belly yes I've explained
this a thousand times Bella Ramsay is playing
Ellie you combine the two you get belly okay
yeah belly belly makes sense um but I thought
they had really good chemistry and there were
a couple times in the DLC that they had some
disagreements but here it got elevated to
a totally different level like where she's
really storms off and then you know comes
back so I was like wow they uh really like
took that to another level in terms of like
them having a major disagreement and Ellie
just being sorry Belly being so so hurt over
you know uh Riley just going leaving uh I
think she said she was going to Atlanta the
Atlanta QC you're just being so devastated
that you know this her best friend and also
someone who she obviously is very affectionate
towards is leaving her and like they really
I mean obviously it was a big deal in the
DLC but it's just it's played a lot more harder
here and I like that they expanded a lot more
on that in again this 50 minute time span
so I thought they uh really again just it
really felt a lot more emotionally gut-wrenching
in terms of when Ellie stormed off and then
she had to come back I mean how'd you feel
about that how do I feel about that just about
them like expanding like them arguing a little
bit more and her being a little more again
I wouldn't say she's more devastated but just
them bickering and arguing a little bit more
than I felt like they did in the DLC and did
you feel that way or do you feel I'm well
no no I think they changed the I think they
changed the context around a little bit here
because they didn't have anything with the
pipe bomb was it pipe bomb yeah I don't remember
DLC they didn't have any of that and they
drive home further in this whole thing too
with they gave me sewage work yes yes like
they they flesh out some other elements where
you see the divide in the path more clear
and I no I did I think for the episode it
totally works um especially when you're trying
to condense down that the DLC because this
feels like the short shorter film version
of that you know and so I think when you are
trying to condense that down you do need some
some more moments because it's a little bit
more subtle in the build up to it what are
you trying to say no no okay I'll keep going
but it's a little more subtle on the build
up to it because they're trying to um because
like in the game you you are seeing her you're
like what's Friday up to you like why does
she want to do this why should I do this and
and Ellie's on to her the whole time but it
takes a while for her to reveal it and so
it's I feel like it's more solemn in the game
you know what I mean it's kind of it's kind
of got this resonating sadness throughout
in the DLC you know we're here you are watching
it unfold and when they do escalate into that
blowout it was it was it was good it was effective
to me um because yeah you do kind of I think
when you're free when I was when you're playing
when you're playing the game it has this interesting
effect where you are just having fun for a
very very long time you are like clicking
the buttons for the photo booth and going
on the Merry-Go-Round and the water the Super
Soakers and then when they're going through
the book it's like you ask like a gazillion
questions and then in the Halloween store
you're playing with that one item the the
was it was like around the Halloween store
yeah over talks back or oh the the skull head
yes it's like the eight ball where you would
ask questions yes that's what it was I'm trying
to remember what it was so you're in it for
such a long time but you're in the back of
your head you're going
guys and yeah the arcade scene I actually
kind of prefer in the game the arcade scene
you know with the with the Turning where it
didn't work and she imagined it right where
she closed her eyes yeah because you are building
the um you were building their connection
throughout and it I I felt like they really
built that emotion where here due to the fact
that you they just probably have no choice
but to like pare it down like you just gotta
pair it down and it has it has some different
scenes in here that I think are very you know
wait for John and Terror so that way they've
never played the game so they're not going
to be doing anything just comparison [__]
um but yeah for for this particular episode
I thought that when it did get to that moment
I found it to be I don't know it wasn't as
like super I'm trying to think if I was like
super impacted by it but uh uh I I I I I really
notice uh as much as you did like you seem
like you really took note of it and I'm like
I feel like I've been searching for words
but at the end of the day I'm like I don't
really take much notice of it because I'm
like it's a show I I was curious to see if
they were actually I I didn't think they were
but I was kind of curious just because there
have been changes here and there expansions
and I was kind of curious if they were going
to show Riley actually turn and then if like
does Ellie have to kill like what did happen
because I don't know like I never read like
I know you know in Wikipedia or whatever they
always have like oh this is what happens to
a character when they don't show stuff on
screen but I was kind of wondering like what
did happen after Riley turned in like did
Ellie have to kill her did the fireflies have
to kill like what happened I was always curious
about that so I I thought maybe they were
going to show that but either way it's it
doesn't impact like my enjoyment of this but
I did that uh it was a very interesting addition
showing Ellie in military training and federal
training rather because obviously in the game
we'd only been taught that had only been a
thing that had been talked about never shown
so again getting another expansion of the
video game I thought that was interesting
just seeing you know ease of her rising to
leadership yeah oh that too of course uh but
I just thought that was again just seeing
what she has to deal with on a daily basis
where I wouldn't say bullying but again just
like I mean would you call that bullying because
I mean the girl was just really getting on
her more because she wasn't like hitting her
laps and they had to do double time because
of her and all that but either way she had
to deal with some form of of abuse and she
was kind of feeling lonely without Riley so
I you know I thought again just even though
we're obviously Beyond emotionally connected
to belly at this point just again just adding
another uh sense of why she doesn't want to
end up alone uh and I just thought again just
a really important expansion showing that
and I thought it was interesting to uh just
circling back to when you know because obviously
Greg and I and all of you who have played
the games you know uh when you know after
they had been bitten she gives uh well the
way I see is we got two options we can either
take the easy way out or what the the second
option that she says we can go crazy with
each other whatever it was I thought that
was interesting I thought that was interesting
were uh Captain Kwan or what um you know the
federal guy uh that he was talking he gave
that he just two options gave the two options
too I was thinking that in the back of my
mind when you said that but again I just I
thought that was really interesting again
the expansion of something that was just talked
about in the video games and then showing
like Ellie and mil and federal training so
I'm glad that they showed that well they they
fleshed out more what the the war between
fedra and fireflies and the political angles
there and choosing choosing the sides here
yeah because yeah that's not it's really not
you know back to that DLC it's really not
about any of that it's it's more the fact
that Riley's going to be leaving is the is
the is the sad part for it but L.A doesn't
seem super perturbed by the fact that it's
the fireflies you know well in the video game
she knows Marlene like they have a history
with each other whereas here she has no idea
who Marlene is because we obviously in the
first episode we saw their first scene together
yeah them meeting each other rather their
introduction to each other so there's a different
dynamic as she really is under the belief
that the fireflies are you know this evil
propaganda machine so it's it adds a different
interesting Dynamic uh you know and a controversy
between the two of them you know a political
Dynamic if you will I thought their chemistry
was great I thought uh belly uh absolutely
what does that mean explain in the comments
I thought belly absolutely killed did I thought
she was great she she felt she does have this
sometimes she does have that Bell around sometimes
does have this uncanny ability with her delivery
where I'm like sounds just like her yeah there
are moments and I did like seeing the the
pain and the the horror that comes with when
she is when she is bit because she has no
idea that she's immune you know it's like
she they feel like their lives are about to
end it's it's such a it's such a mean sometimes
the world The Last of Us can't be very mean
it is like I remember when I played the dlz
and then the way the kiss went down and was
like don't go kisses okay like she agrees
not to go then and then the second half and
I remember like crying when I'm playing the
game like at that moment because I got hit
with they're about to kill her off her yeah
it's such a mean like the [__] with Henry
and Sam and that's what I mean by dramatic
irony like we as the audience we know what's
about to happen whereas the characters don't
but it's still like is so effective yeah the
the the world of Last of Us and Neil druckman
and Company often have a habit of going and
something that our choice is to make with
this show sometimes see where they're like
how can we make this sadder make Sam deaf
like they just drive it home even harsher
every time and yeah yeah I do I've always
found I've always found her little funny how
mean the last of us can actually go out of
their way to go all right but right when that
comes around then they're gonna die and it
was and uh the choice to make it one uh is
it a stalker uh yeah it was a stalker it was
a stalker typically not a clicker make it
one stalker versus a horde that you have to
escape through uh I thought especially if
you haven't played the game does make it more
effective because I mean demonstrates how
hard one person is yeah and this episode in
particular made me go God that makeup must
take [__] forever oh yeah um but you know
especially if you haven't played the game
you I think it's easier to get more hopeful
that everything's gonna that everything might
have turned out all right you know you're
where you're watching a flashback and the
the fact that Riley died in the first episode
yeah of course and also too I mean they they
uh they they showed us The Horde already you
know and what was it two episodes ago so I
I was not expecting to see another one I I
was expecting maybe to see one or two at most
in this but I got to imagine too with the
amount of viewership that they've gotten in
the season that you know possibly next season
uh which is not going to be controversial
at all uh that there's gonna be uh I would
imagine that there's going to be a little
bit more ramped up in terms of the action
when it comes to the the infected but again
the show's not about the infected it's just
it's it's it's partition yeah it's it they're
in the background obviously if you add if
you add that in there great I mean you're
gonna you're gonna get a lot of people extra
excited about those action sequences of course
but I mean this makes sense in in the in the
TV show this makes sense to just have one
stalker like it's totally totally understandable
to have one yeah I can't quite put my I think
the only thing I can do that it can be very
honest about and it's just a sad unfortunate
reality of it is I I can't quite put my finger
on what did not necessarily fully work for
me about this episode and the sad part is
is that it it feel like it's mainly because
because at any time I have a criticism that's
actually popping in my Noggin I I'm trying
to do the mental work of yeah but is it just
because I'm comparing it to what the game
did because especially harder when it's so
much like the game yeah yeah and then and
then it could feel like a very because for
the most part it felt like a shorter version
of the DLC that's that's what it mainly felt
like so in my head and with a video game which
the DLC had played on on a PS5 with like beautiful
graphics and everything I feel like I've seen
a more fleshed out version already and and
this seems like the shorter version to me
like a remake of it so I find my mind going
I thought the game did it better because I
got to spend more time in everything and so
I have to like check my Noggin on it and I
don't know I know other people I've definitely
talked with plenty of other people who have
gone through it I know plain other people
who've played it who haven't gone through
it so it's kind of weird to do a reaction
and then be like I feel like I have criticisms
but I'm not I'm doubting my criticism so much
because I feel like it's only because I played
a video game yeah and I'm like I have really
this is the first episode out of them all
where I I'm super questionable about would
I feel any of these things that felt like
rush to me if you had if I hadn't played the
game you know no it's understanding do you
get where I'm coming from I'm really doubting
like I don't know if I should like I don't
even know if any of this is like the valid
criticism in my own head because I I feel
like I'm just comparing it to the extended
version that I thought did it better yeah
no I mean I don't I mean time comparison Wise
It's hard to compare so uh but I I get where
you're coming from like I said for me not
doing the the game comparison stuff just just
my little nitpicky stuff there were a couple
times where at the beginning when they're
getting to the mall uh again there were some
some of the dialogue I really enjoyed but
it was just it was dragging a little bit for
me personally you know if it didn't for you
great uh just uh thought it dragged just a
little bit um and again me being the nitpicker
I am I thought they were being way too loud
and I was going to pull you out of the reality
yeah they're supposed it's two or three in
the morning and and she's a firefly and they're
sneaking around in a federal territory yeah
so I mean the whole point is literally to
be as silent as possible and again obviously
we need to hear the dialogue but I'm not saying
Saints but I mean in a volume that's a little
more reasonable than this you know like it's
not a big deal that we're talking so loud
like we're not sneak just stuff like that
but I mean again I I hear what you're saying
I get it um but do you have any of that issue
at all do you struggle that at all at all
I mean there's times where it's like I talk
to other people who do as well but I notice
you you don't ever seem like you do I mean
there's times but I I always say this look
I got my video game version I love what they're
doing for sure it's it's not as long as the
game and they can't copy it you know beat
for beat shot for shot everything so it's
it's hard to make a full-on like sure yeah
it's gotta be the exact same thing but it's
it's it's I get where you're coming from it's
it's called The Last of Us it's the same character
so I I get why like in the back your head
like it was done and executed like this was
fleshed out longer so I get why I'm gonna
my brain is just it I'm trying not to make
a comparison to what I'm so used to seeing
and so used to playing it's like the length
of things you know like when they like when
they put when they when when the scene like
the scene the reason that the book scene um
like when when the book pop the the pun book
pops up and hear why it's so awesome for for
people at the game is because of a very memorable
scene in the DLC and like that like that scene
has so much emotion and all they're doing
is laughing and criticizing the puns and stuff
but it's such an impactful scene for some
reason in the game it's so impactful and that
you really do feel like you're lost on a night
on the town yeah where here the I didn't ever
truly get lost in uh in a mood for the night
you know yeah and that's the that was the
part of it that I I felt like uh because it's
the whole thing like I want to show you a
good time but you were suspecting something
else that and they constantly had this like
melancholic undertone and here it I I felt
like it was like a big uh because I I don't
I can't I don't know how to formula it's no
I get what you're saying but it's hard to
explain but I think the people who played
the video game like understand what you're
saying too but I think for me the biggest
disappointment I have from this episode is
the pun that they didn't use what did the
cannibal get when he was late to the party
a cold shoulder that's the one I was most
disappointed that they missed but nah dude
I I truly get where you're coming from like
of course your brain is just naturally used
to we've played the game so many times so
look and the same thing happens for me and
I I try and check myself out like when it
comes to the MCU versus have you watched uh
Earth's Mightiest Heroes yet or I know you
started it but if you out okay well I started
reading the comics instead okay I mean again
I I think Earth's Mightiest Heroes is miles
above the MCU but MCU is still phenomenal
and I just at some points I just I check myself
out and go you know what MCU does a good job
of its own thing so I I just got to check
myself out here and just say hey this is a
good thing here too and I still got Myers
Mightiest Heroes and that's a great thing
too so but I get what you're saying it's it's
totally understandable it's not you doing
it on purpose it's just your brain is so used
to from the game version so it's it's understandable
yeah because I don't even miss the stuff of
yeah like I I think it's awesome when Ellie's
in the mall and and having to look for she's
just trying to find like a freaking first
aid kit yeah and and it's it's an adventure
and she's really badass and it's a struggle
it's a lot and it's it's the most exciting
part of the gameplay because you're because
that's when you're actually dealing with scared
that [__] the whole time right it's really
and I can imagine there's a part of the audience
who's like I oh man they totally skipped over
that and to me that doesn't even bother me
that they skipped over that it's more when
I'm watching something where like most of
this is pretty much scene for scene but I'm
aware of I'm aware of the fact that yeah there's
there's it's more of the tone that's missing
for me not really the placement there there
is that like the part where I thought it was
most captured was when they're on the Merry-Go-Round
yeah like that's kind of the underlying mood
of the entire thing that is perfect yeah I
agree with you on the flip side of that there
are times and moments where I'm like oh my
God I'm glad they added that or there was
a timeline oh definitely that was actually
well that was better that was actually better
than the game so like yeah there can be you
know flip effect to that as well like you
know in the first episode I love that whole
moment where they're explaining what the quarter
steps uh you know brain infection can be the
foreshadowed like that was great obviously
not in the video game the second episode just
uh where you know the woman is studying and
what it isn't like bomb the whole like that's
not gonna get like lots of stuff like that
that that's not like again it works both ways
so I I get totally what you're saying and
you know there are times where my my brain
is thinking that like it's not the game but
yeah it I just checked myself out when that
happens and I'm just I think I still think
this is one of if not the best video game
adaptations yeah yeah we're just we're trying
to find nitpicky things in a pretty damn perfect
show yeah like uh no slight to the actress's
author amazing they're absolutely amazing
and I like the structure of it and it was
the I mean come on we're seven episodes in
and we've obviously I'd still give the show
like a 99 yeah I think also too a Greg's trying
to correlate as well is like as a writer it's
not easy like for someone like even Neil druckman
who's the creator and you know this is his
baby yeah one and two and even Craig um Mason
right Craig Mason uh it's not easy to condense
something down like to uh you know from an
hour and a half in the video game DLC to like
45 50 minutes into a TV show and like hit
the same you know effect level like as it
was in but they they get pretty damn close
so you know you give them credit where credit's
due so but I I totally feel where you're coming
from for sure I mean they deal with time Jump
share in interesting ways because they they
cut to the in the house and it did make me
question like how come no one's like trying
to chase after them I just I just I'm not
even doing like a game comparison I feel like
they they could have based off the way the
last episode ended I I thought with the whole
blood being all over the place they left a
trail of the boys I feel like they could have
I feel like because they only took because
only one person attacked right in the last
episode yeah because yeah but they had several
other people I'm like what was their mode
of transportation they can't chase after them
yeah or they just camped out there at the
University right so that's like an actual
like question in my head of like okay how
come none of them are chasing after them um
yeah like I know some game [__] obviously
coming up whatever but I'm but I'm saying
even if like like completely removing the
game yeah I found myself questioning like
no one's chasing them this is kind of weird
that no one's chasing them right now um which
the DLC does actually fill in because of the
game itself too they yeah the dude cut too
she they're just hit out there um but they
they do fill that in the DLC of them chasing
but it does make me go like logically you'd
think some of them would be Jason chasing
them right now right so yeah all right overall
I honestly all things said I would still give
this like at least an eight out of ten like
I I know I I know it sounds like I had a major
qualm with it but like I said I'm I'm really
like no I mean what they brought to life they
did really yeah I just I I feel like they
there's this is great I just think there's
a this episode made me Hyper aware there's
a much greater version of this in my living
room waiting to be played uh and and that
was basically that where but no other episode
really uh kind of evoked that for me so 8
out of ten you hated it yeah yeah and I might
have put a little I'm really looking forward
to this episode in particular too and uh maybe
there was a bit of over expectation yeah of
delivering like just uh that drama down because
yeah like the like the mood of there's a reason
I prefer the whole thing whether it's like
just imagine it with the arcade game The Turning
yeah yeah like that that that enhances the
romance between them you know yeah are you
say fatalities don't enhance the romance come
on fatalities dude do you know how many people
have bonded over fatalities yeah in the arcade
I like when they had more time to like simmer
in their um and their romantic connection
because that kind of just builds in the game
you know yeah I think there's something there
it just keeps getting bigger and bigger yeah
and I think the the crescendo to the kiss
is is much more felt than in here so I could
have just said that 15 minutes ago and I think
I would have easily uh alleviated my what
I was trying to say all righty guys well leave
your thoughts down below subscribe leave a
like and uh
Ricardo Martinez Ricardo my friend I am so
happy you've been part of our patreon page
for such a long time now we're in 2023 and
you know what dude from everything you've
ever told us about yourself which is primarily
that you are Latino I want to know a little
bit more about you so when you see this shot
and I know one day you will I'm expecting
a message in my patreon inbox telling me some
fun details about yourself I want you to answer
these five questions for me one what is your
favorite color ice cream two what would you
say is the most inspirational film you've
ever seen three tell me about your most traumatic
experience in one sentence four how many girls
or guys have you been with five what's your
favorite show you're currently watching I
want you to answer all five of them one sentence
only please do not do more than that or else
it's going to be so much response I'm gonna
have to do so Ricardo thank you for being
part of here but it's time to know more about
you other than your general ethnicity that
you uh you know subscribe to that you chose
to be a part of [Music]